hey guys it is Monday the fifteenth of
September today my name is just Whittle
and you're watching the games but you
sir the destiny review started rolling
in last week and so did the claim from
Bungie that the game totally transforms
after 20 hours you guys have had an
awful lot to say on this one either way
but depending on how far you r in Bungie
are pretty sure you'll be playing
totally different games executive
producer Patrick o'kelly explains that
players 20-plus hours in will line that
they're immersed in a different world
and a deep into the history of their
characters they'll have built a
community of other players and without
realizing it they'll have learned some
sophisticated mechanics that enable them
to gear up and dive into a six fair
cooperative raid in pursuit of
high-level exotic weapons and armor if
you're playing this one dropped me a
comment to let me know how much of this
you found to be true in your destiny
game so far just a short while after
hearing the GTA 5 on PC had not been
delayed or cancelled we've received
official word that it has in fact been
delayed well at least they were half
right that story rolled in last week but
today Rockstar have offered up something
of an explanation as to why PC fans are
going to have to wait until next year to
do some video game crimes essentially
it's a very similar line to the one we
hear every time a game gets a delay the
devs need more time to make the game
polished and amazing last up today that
report that Microsoft was going to buy
minecraft crater mojang turned out to be
totally true and here's everything you
need to know about that approximately
2.5 billion dollars changed hands for
the acquisition and mojang is already
doing damage control to make sure gamers
know that minecraft will remain
available on non-microsoft platforms
Marcus after said the reason they bought
the studio is to add diversity to their
portfolio and to reach new gamers across
other platforms Mojang's co-founders
Markus notch Persson and Jacob Corsa as
well as executive calm many will all be
leaving the company person has expressed
that he never intended to
companies so significant and that the
pressure of owning minecraft was too
much for him in a follow-up statement
notch said it's not about the money it's
about my sanity explaining I've become a
symbol I don't want to be a symbol
responsible for something huge that I
don't understand that I don't want to
work on that keeps coming back to me I'm
not an entrepreneur I'm not a CEO I'm a
nerdy computer programmer who likes to
have opinions on Twitter as for your
question of the day let me know what you
think of the acquisition if you're after
more gaming news you can head to gain
spot where we've got stories on the
potential release date of super smash
brothers for you and the goal of EA
access that is all I wanted to tell you
about today be sure to drop me your
thoughts and I will catch you same time
and place tomorrow